in taking on these characters I mean you
you two are both actors with
extraordinary commitment to the truth of
a performance and the interior life of a
character being expressed in sincere
terms in the case of this film these
characters also have an iconic presence
and they're part of a grand visual
design that's going on and I was curious
to ask both of you in how do you balance
in your process the sincerity of the
interior process with the the
understanding of the iconic nature of
the character you first
I really
I've worked with him before so I think I
can answer this and it was a great
experience on my my tab
I think I get it but you're you're
you're at and and I I think one of the
things that at least I tried having seen
Bob and known in my whole life
really and admired him mine and so it at
at the onset I thought I don't know if I
mentioned it to Michael but I thought
there should be that difference in in in
the characters in terms of their how
they come off how they're you know what
colors they're they're in and I thought
that you know the more introverted or
extroverted I thought that would help
with a balance so so we had talked about
it I think Michael I mean yeah help me
at all here and but there was that was
part of it and I and I think I took a
liberté we did both we had talked about
him I know that I my character's
situation is different than his and and
I'm all my life is falling apart in his
is just starting and and and and that
was a key for me anyway and I and also
the carrot I don't know if this has
gotten out much I don't know if I've
ever said it but I might be breaking the
law now but I'll say it be the character
I played is is a guy he's like he's been
around he done a lot of stuff and he
also chips cocaine and I I always
thought that that was a a choice we made
and and but yet not not showing it
because it would be somewhat
it was a little trek too much attention
how to attract too much yeah but there
is a scene in it where it goes by really
quick but which we never get never got
into the film and I've always wanted to
say sometimes just so you know where is
some of the behaviors coming from okay I
never thought I'd ever have that
opportunity to say this just you know
elegant audience here that I could
actually anyway I've had to say it for
20 years and I thanks for this
opportunity Mike are you okay well thank
you now what how it answers your
question it's kind of vague and around
and around but it sort of does you know
yeah no it absolutely does
no mr. DeNiro what was the question here
FairPoint Neal he's a very iconic figure
in the design of the film and yet he's
played with total sincerity as a as a
psychological realistic character and
they're all they're all kinds of nuances
to it that I'm curious about
and maybe it's too intimate question it
tells you your process but for example I
mean he has an extraordinary
extraordinarily acute perception of the
world and of what's going around him and
yet at times an unbelievable blind spot
particularly his relationship with Edie
you know when he strolls casually in and
you know his drinking his drink and
think about everything's going on and
expects her to just come come with him
and I'm sort of curious as to the how
you approach that psychology there's
blind spots
with somebody who's that that sharp well
you know Michael wrote the script and
the thing about and the characters the
thing about Michael is that he's he
creates a tension in the in the whole
approach of the film even in the prep in
our training and everything it's a whole
kind of it just it kind of affects you
where you know every moment is I don't
want to say precious but kind of
important so the things that like the
what you're talking about and I'm not I
can't think specifically but all I know
is that whatever he does it just makes
the move whatever he did was important
and creates a tension if you will or a
tautness what else could I say what we
all did together the three we sit
together and everybody and veil and and
and actually telling me Brennan at the
anthon or everybody and John Voight was
we spent a lot of time building their
histories so what the film is is the
right now of it what what preceded that
was very specific very detailed history
that we really immersed we really
immersed ourselves in why and how Hannah
is a hunter why he truly is and he's
somebody who is all I am is who I'm
going after and why how he is completely
self-aware there's no self-deception and
the only other person who was as
conscious and unselfish his new McAuley
and what was Neil McCauley doing when
his father disappeared and he and his
brother got remanded and they wound up
in an shins in Gladiator Academy's like
Tracy or Chino and he lost track was
father lost track was a brother and then
graduated into crime and at what point
this very bright guy decided I have to
figure out which is something observed
with convicts and who I Brayden
Penitentiary's and likely false in 52
70s by the way when they had a lot more
programs in the institutions and they
were really go into guys with third or
fourth grade education with walking on
libraries and say give me a book that
tells me about time tells me about my
life I got to figure out what I'm going
to do or I'm just going to say hello
gray walls
life is yours and surrender to a life in
prison and instead of that people like
Neil McCauley and this was part of the
backstory and this part The Bachelor
we'll call it people like new equality
find out what they think time is that
time is short and has to be invested and
if you don't invest in it and have
experience it's your fault and it's not
going to happen
and then they continue to read and it
could read marks and decide that
property is theft and it becomes a
justification for stealing or they get
into Buddhism and they decide that if
anything happens to all the other people
that's their working out their bad karma
what all the so there's some of the
philosophical underpinnings that is
factual and part of the backstory of who
Neil McCauley is when he gets out and
technicolor is going to be the zealand
refugee and always a weigh station on
the way to somewhere else and then how
does he minimalize risk by being
anonymous so it's a gray suit and white
shirts it's hard to describe him and no
attachments so that people can't the
cops can't cut into his communications
and talk to people like et so it's not
supposed to be a needy
once there is a needy in the in his life
it was supposed to be temporary and
that's why he's not going back but then
he succumbs the seduction and calls or
and does go back with her but is that
the fatalism of the film oven we were
talking about outcomes and talk about
each character the way fate works was
just something we just invented which is
that well what happened to each
character is a function of the way he
thinks life works
so it's Kara totally character driven
and and Neil believing that being very
doctrinaire and not having attachments
and that's it's very efficient and
affected a navigation system through the
weigh station if he deviates from that
which he does and the under palisades
when he's talking was talking to Edie he
defeat deviates from that then there has
to be a repercussion and cause and
effect will be brutal so the neo who is
flying free and as and is moved by
emotions like vengeance or rage or
deciding to go after Wayne grown it the
Neil for the beginning of the movie
wouldn't
I would never go an afternoon win-win
bro so that's the when whereas another
cure for like Val Kilmer who was going
to postmodern and doesn't have doctrine
doesn't have discipline he skates so
what happened to them they're failures
of function to who they were characters
in the engine of the story in the way it
drives to the end